we were born into a world at war between  the monsters that destroyed our cities  and the monsters we created to stop them  we thought we had sacrificed enough  Pacific Rim by its nature is massive  you're dealing with 270 foot mechs and  giant kaiju the monsters that have  better just as big and because the film  is gigantic and monstrous there's  nothing better than IMAX to display that  and to feel the full glory and the  magnificence and the spectacle of what's  going on and I remember sitting down for  my first time in seeing this movie on  the IMAX screens and it was incredible  and I had seen the movie a hundred times  but nothing prepares you for the IMAX  experience it is spectacular gonna be a  long day  we fight  [Music]